so we're both huge fans of the Marc
Maron WTF podcast oh yeah and part of
the beauty of what Mark does is that he
seems to admit very dark things about
himself and and you know even his
jealousies toward other comics or actors
resentments addictions etc do you think
a good comic should go into therapy in
order to know sort of the things about
themselves that are sort of the blind
spots a lot of people don't want to
admit I personally think that their
stand up is their therapy that now is
stand-ups basically rat they talked
about what's making them crazy and it's
a very nice way to get at those things
and you know very few stand-ups or
saying things like I just had my kitchen
remodel it's so beautiful now I just
like to stand there not the double doors
for the refrigerator oh my goodness yeah
that's not gonna happen and you say the
freaking contractor do you know you so
it I mean I've spoken to a lot of them
that say it really is that's that's how
I deal with it so should someone says
let's suppose therapy isn't working for
some people it works for they enjoy it
they have a very great relationship with
their therapists and others do you think
they need that audience validation and
that can be another way to work through
things you're asking a bunch of very
difficult questions on the therapy part
of course considering that i do
moonlight is a clinical psychologist of
course i think everybody should be in
therapy but for stand-ups um you know
stand up being a stand-up has two
different facets there's the performance
part of it and there's there the writing
part of it and it's really the writing
part that you're getting into you and
I what I can do is tell you a parallel
story of a friend of mine who said in
that very chair and was writing a
screenplay said I'm just stuck I just
ripped myself into a corner I can't seem
to get out of and I sat down with him
and I said let's play a little bit and
you be your main character and let's do
a psych history and I took a very
detailed psych history and by the time
he left he said no matter what happens
to this character I know how he'll react
no matter what situation he's into I
know how will view it and found
enormously helpful you also had a oh you
said a one-time stint at The Comedy
Store you were yeah yeah listen well I
agree everyone should be in therapy and
it's always the people who don't go who
need to go who make life miserable for
the rest of us that's my
non-professional I'm opinion I I'm a
complete believer I think therapy is
really helpful for your creative people
and I I don't I think it's a
superstition to believe that if you talk
about your demons that you will I think
it's a defense mechanism about having to
deal with them because I've never met a
creative person who who went to therapy
was harmed by it unless they had like
you know a charlatan or you know
somebody who like the guy you know the
famous Beach Boys story about Brian
Wilson having this guy gene Landry who
kind of took over his life that's that's
a little different um that can happen I
guess but it's I don't think it's that
common um you would have to say if it's
common they're very uncommon yeah um but
um I just like to take over the
financial part of their life I i I'm
gonna just pretend you didn't say that
matter um I had again my longtime
writing partner who came out of stand-up
and sketch comedy
talked me into doing it one night at an
open mic at The Comedy Store and I froze
I just just you know we planned it out
we rode it out it was great and I kept
saying her all the way through I'm not
mil Gaya you'll be fine I'll feed you
the lines you're funny I said I'm great
in a living room and I'm okay on the
page but I can't again I got up there
and I it was that cliched thing of
looking out and seeing a sea of faces
and it was like the flop sets even seen
the flop sweat scene from broadcast news
you know when Albert Brooks is just
sweating and sweating and sweating and
can't stop sweating that was me and I
just never did it again but my daughter
does it which is really interesting and
she's very good in fact next execs uh
what's today Wednesday Saturday night
she's going to the comedy store and
doing the third or fourth time she's
done it but she's had some training and
she loves performing and the thing is is
like I stopped performing in 11th grade
when I went up in my lines you know in a
play and hit my forehead and the drama
teacher said do it again tomorrow night
and that was the last I'm not an actor I
have no my wife's an actress a wonderful
actress in that it's about as close as I
get to act
you